the Kurds there is a world's largest
ethnic group without a country they're
spread across one of the most volatile
regions in the world and you've
definitely heard of them Kurdish
militias across Iraq and Syria have
gained some popularity in the United
States but there still isn't much
support for an independent Kurdish state
why is that the case well it's
complicated
hey guys I'm Sunna this is AJ plus and
this Sunday I want to talk about why
making a Kurdish state happen is gonna
be tough so the Kurds have been getting
a lot of international attention in the
last few years because of their role in
the conflicts in Iraq and Syria Kurdish
militias have been battling Isis Syrian
rebels the Iraqi and Syrian government's
to stake claim to land and to also
protect Kurdish communities and October
2017 Kurds in Iraqi Kurdistan took part
in a referendum in which 93% of those
who voted chose independence but the
Iraqi government called a referendum
illegal and non-binding and while the
referendum was considered a big moment
in Kurdish political history what
happened in Iraqi Kurdistan didn't
necessarily represent the direction of
all Kurdish people and Annisa coogee a
lecturer at UC Berkeley breaks down why
that's the case
there is no single Kurdish independence
movement after the world war 1 Kurdistan
was divided into four nation-states Iran
Iraq Turkey and Syria so with that let's
roll back a bit and look at how the
Kurds have ended up where they are today
the Kurds are the fourth largest ethnic
group in the region and make up sizeable
minority populations across Iran Iraq
Syria and Turkey despite having big
numbers they didn't get their own state
after the fall of the Ottoman Empire
when the United Kingdom and France were
busy carving up the region the infamous
sykes-picot agreement split the Ottoman
Empire into nation-states but it didn't
really care about how ethical a diverse
the region actually was the Kurds left
out of sykes-picot had negotiated their
own state under the Treaty of 7 but that
didn't work out the treaty was supposed
to split modern-day turkey into
different zones including one for the
Kurds but it wasn't ratified thanks to
one Turkish nationalists led by Kemal
Ataturk Turkey's first president Riek
after all of modern turkey from the
Europeans fast forward to the 1930s 40s
and 50s when we start seeing countries
across the region and gain independence
from European colonialism a huge part of
pushing back against European
colonialism was the cultivation of
various nationalisms pan-arabism for
instance turkeys camel ism or Iranian
nationalism all of this meant that
Kurdish sovereignty was either not a
priority for pan Erebus leaders in Iraq
and Syria or was a threat for Kamala's
Turkey and for Iran that meant that over
the 20th century the Kurds across these
four countries saw a lot of
marginalization there was displacement
political repression loss of rights and
massacres and it's not as though the
Kurds didn't resist our oppression time
and time again they did now the brunt of
the state violence faced by Kurds was in
Turkey in Iraq in Turkey the government
forcibly displaced
over a million Kurds after several
Kurdish revolts in the 1920s and 30s
Kurdish language and culture was banned
and violence against a Kurdish
population including torture and
destruction of villages was widespread
Kurds in Iraq saw the height of state
repression in the late 80s and early 90s
under the leadership of Saddam Hussein
the Iraqi government / saw several
massacres of Kurdish civilians during
the iran-iraq war the government accused
Kurdish fighters along the Iranian
border of assisting the Iranians and led
what was called the unfought campaign it
lasted two years and claimed thousands
of Kurdish lives by the end of the 1980s
Iraq in the 90s saw the first Gulf War
a Kurdish civil war and hundreds of
thousands of Iraqi deaths as a result of
the international sanctions then we get
to the early 2000s where there was the
American invasion of Iraq so that brings
us now to today a push for Kersh
independence and the resistance to it
Iraqi Kurdish journalist Abdullah hueso
told me how it's important to think of
Kurdistan as more than just a political
aspiration so the idea of having a
Kurdish state is not only political
dream it's actually part of the culture
of Kurds it's part of their identity
they have been raised with thinking that
Kurds deserve a state so who's standing
in the way let's start with Turkey and
Iran Iran and Turkey are very much
against the establishment of a Kurdish
state
even outside of their borders because
they feel that if there is a Kurdish
political entity anywhere in the Middle
East this would threaten the so-called
national unity of these two countries
turkey considers groups like the PKK aka
the Kurdistan Workers Party to be
terrorist groups and threats to national
security Turkey also fears an
independent Kurdish state in Iraq would
be used as a base for the PKK to launch
attacks on the Turkish military and
civilian populations Turkish
nationalists seek Kurdish aspirations
inside its borders and outside as a
threat to while Turkish state identity
remember I mentioned how back in the
1930s Kurds were barred in Turkey from
speaking their own language and
practicing your own culture well it was
only in 2012 that they were allowed to
teach their own language and culture in
private schools
then there's Iran Iran also has no
interest in seeing an independent
Kurdish state given its own Kurdish
population in the country's Northwest as
well as its relationship with Iraq
currently Iran has very close relations
with the Iraqi government seeing it as a
buffer between itself and hostile
regional neighbors a Kurdish state that
would be seen as friendly to the United
States and Israel isn't exactly the most
tantalizing thought for the Iranians
then we've got Iraq and Syria both
embroiled in conflict following the
Kurdish referendum the Iraqi government
responded by launching an offensive to
take the city of Kirkuk which had been
under control since 2014 voiced by the
way says that Kirkuk is central to
Kurdish statehood
it's considered a vital part of any
Kurdish project for statehood not only
because of its wealth and its oil which
is actually very important for for any
any Kurdish state especially
economically but also historically were
staying without her cube a quarter state
would be very poor even culturally then
there's Syria workers have seen some
reforms in recent years and workers
forces have been integral in the battle
against Isis in 2011 as protests were
spreading across Syria the government
granted around 300,000 undocumented
Kurds citizenship citizenship that was
stripped back in 1962 but serious Kurds
are seeking a federal system in
the country similar to Iraqi Kurdistan's
autonomous position as for the Americans
while they've supported the Kurds
throughout the decades they don't
actually support a Kurdish state
according to the official line a Kurdish
state in Iraq where the movement is the
strongest who would mean further
destabilization of a vital US ally but
its closest ally in the region Israel
has actually been vocally supportive of
an independent Kurdish state Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu sees
Kurdistan as a potential ally for Israel
in a region where it feels surrounded by
well not that many allies so what is the
likelihood of there being a Kurdish
state anytime soon or at all
well according to ways not too likely
Kurds have realized without have seeking
support from their regional and
international powers it's almost
impossible to build a state especially
that Kurdistan is a small region and
it's landlocked surrounded by hostile
countries so for that it's very
difficult to build a state without
building a strong diplomatic approaches
it's also worth noting that not all
Kurdish populations follow the Iraqi
Kurdish movement for independence per se
when you look at other parts of
Kurdistan for instance the Turkish part
the Syrian part in both parts - Kurdish
nationalist movement is not asking for
independence actually they are seeking a
solution within the existing borders so
they're trying to democratize
the state so that no curse would have a
favorable environment and as AQG also
says that lack of political cohesion is
because of weak leadership it has a lot
to do with the fragmentation of the
Kurdish society along tribal regional
and linguistic lines and again the
inability of the Kurdish leadership to
bring all the segments together to
create one voice which would carry the
curse - initially the Kurds have a long
history of not only marginalization but
of resisting that marginalization but
given how the Kurdistan region is
surrounded by hostile countries lacks
political cohesion and even agreement on
the nation's future it's not very likely
that the world's largest nation without
a state will be getting one anytime soon
so we barely scratched the surface when
it comes to the career
independence movement encouraged
politics in general let us know in the
comments what other communities that are
searching for homeland you want to know
about and don't forget to like share and
subscribe and come back next Sunday when
we come at you with another video